では始まります そういうことで
本格的に悪魔という概念ね
もうどうやって登場するのかっていうこと
それで妄想の世界で悪魔が登場する
我々の妄想の世界で悪魔がいるんです
自分が良いことをしたい人間なのに
悪魔に誘惑されているってことですね
神様 悪魔の誘惑に勝てるようにしてくださいと神頼みもする
人は悪に走るのは自然の流れです
本能です だからもうとっくにいるんです
わざわざ作らなくてもいいんです
だから他宗教では悪魔は後から登場するんですけど
仏教は輪廻と言ったら
まあそこでも悪があるんです
本来良い人間でしたが
後悪魔に誘惑されたではありません
悪はいつから現れたのでしょうかと妄想することもあまりにも愚かです
よく哲学者はやるんですね
悪はいつから生まれた
悪って何なの？よく分析
小説まで書いてありますね
悪について 神話に頼らない人々は
それで神話は嫌やと思っている人々は
自然の流れだ 悪いことをしないと生きていられないのだ
殺生しないと食べられない
ないのだ これ何の間違い？食べられないのだ
悪はあるが仕方がありませんと悪を正当化するんです
それで信仰 迷信 いわゆる神話信じてる人々は
悪魔に怯えて とにかく悪いことをしないようにと怯えながら悪いことしているんです
ものすごくむちゃくちゃ
信仰は何でもない 宗教はないという人々は
もう悪を正当化するんです
殺生しないでやれるんでしょうかとかね
商売できるわけないでしょう
と それは当たり前でしょうと
生きるために必要でしょうとかなんだらかんだり言いながら
また同じ悪を犯して生活しているのです
だから 神を信じるか信じないかと関係なく
人間というのはみんな同じ
悪ことばっかりやってるんです
それで仏教から言えば
輪廻が悪魔なんです いわゆる生きていること
神の味方になって悪魔と戦ってみても
好意に善悪判断はつかないと悪を否定しても
いわゆる神の味方になって
我々人間は神の味方 私も
だから悪魔と戦ってやろうと思っても意味がない
善行に判断できないと
世の中現代人みたいな
このわけじゃないんだよと分かってたと
現代人ならそう思っている
そんなことをしても 皆また生き続けるために夢中になっている
これは違いますね これは生きるの生きです
生き続けるために夢中になっている
色と勘違いしている 自分を守ろうとしている
何やってる？例えば現代人は認めないでしょう
善悪あるんだと しょうがないでしょう
仕方がないでしょうという態度でしょ
結局現代人も何をやっているのかというと
この自分を守ろうとしているんです
自分の生き方 そのままで
神の味方になって悪を潰そうとしている人々も
結局は自分の生き方を守ろうとしているのです
生きること自体 輪廻そのものが人に苦しみをもたらす悪魔なのです
生きることで苦しみが生まれるんですよ
生きることに愚痴が生まれているんですよ
だから生きることそのもの
そのシステム自体が悪魔なんです
だからまた因果法則だから
一回だけ生まれて 生きていて
死んで消えるならばいいんだけど
そんな法則ってないんですから
もう延々と続けちゃいます
せっちゃうから 一切修行は悪魔です
悪魔に会ったことがないと思うでしょ
嫌になるほど会ってるんです
悪魔以外誰にも会わないんです